oh yeah that's a good duo not smells
really good
that's delicious head where this is a
perfume
I love cookies I love butter I don't
know why would it my I mean if there's a
way to make cookie better to put it in
liquid form so you can ingest it faster
I think it's gonna taste like creamy
cookie dough it's gonna taste like
melted cookies and angels and angels
what is speculoos that is the name of an
old clock maker with a hidden past yeah
all you have to do is taste it to
understand well is that how food goes
pretty talk isn't that like a pickup
line some dude would probably say to a
girl cheese like your light bulb it's
like a sweet peanut butter it tastes
like a Teddy Graham melted in my mouth
yeah it's like if you just melt it down
cookies like whip them up and then put
in this little candle jar like peanut
butter in Christmas I would definitely
consider mixed like just experimenting
with this getting crazy with it this is
thick this is like cement for your mouth
it's like eating a mouthful of mud yeah
but good mud seriously you can put this
on anything you put this on my
ex-boyfriend and it would make him
better I think it's really great to have
this kind of cookie taste in in more of
a spreadable form I just wanted to be
socially acceptable to have cookies for
breakfast yeah I can't talk I'm just a
full of this stuff almond butter or
cashew butter everything's butter these
days you know what let's step away from
butter and let's just think like do we
even need it you better believe it